[Música]
Colombia y Venezuela normalizaron sus
relaciones bilaterales la llegada de
Gustavo Petro a la presidencia de
Colombia abrió la puerta para que Bogotá
y Caracas restablecieran a pleno nivel
la presencia diplomática y más
recientemente también pues el
intercambio comercial en la frontera
veamos algunos datos de contexto para
entender la situación allí Colombia
Venezuela comparten una extensa frontera
común de unos 2.200 kilómetros de largo
cerca de 6.2 fronterizos oficiales han
sido establecidos entre las autoridades
de ambos países dicha frontera fue
cerrada en el año 2015 por diferencias
políticas entre ambos países pero el
momento más bajo de las relaciones llegó
con la ruptura por completo de las
relaciones entre Caracas y Bogotá en el
año 2018 cuando el entonces presidente
Iván Duque reconoció junto a otros 50
países alrededor del mundo a Juan guaidó
como presidente oficial de Venezuela
el cierre de la frontera pues partió la
vida de muchas personas de muchas
familias que hacen una vida
interfronteriza digámoslo así viven en
Venezuela pero hacen compras y estudian
en Colombia o viceversa y el gigantesco
intercambio en las zonas urbanas
interfronterizas también se vio
seriamente afectado veamos algunas
cifras para ponernos en contexto Estos
son según cifras oficiales que son
presentadas por el gobierno colombiano
entonces de acuerdo a estas cifras el
intercambio comercial entre ambos países
para el año 2006 llegaba a los 2000
millones de dólares anuales cifra que se
incrementó hasta 5000 millones de
dólares para el año 2008 actualmente es
intercambio debido al cierre de la
frontera solamente llega a unos 300
millones anuales el embajador de
Colombia en Caracas Armando Benedetti ha
dicho que son muy optimistas con el
intercambio entre los dos países y
esperan que este llega a los 10 mil
millones de dólares anuales
Esta es una frontera que es muy porosa
es difícil de controlar y por eso su
cierre allí pues afectó a todas las
personas que viven a lo largo y ancho de
la frontera existe un tránsito
clandestino de personas de Contrabando y
también de mafias criminales que operan
allí y que se han hecho prácticamente
con el control de las zonas generando
serios problemas de criminalidad
violaciones de los derechos humanos y
también pues una economía clandestina
por supuesto pero vamos allí al terreno
a donde están sucediendo los hechos
vamos a Cúcuta del lado colombiano de la
frontera Allí se encuentra Daniela
Blandón para conocer más detalles
adelante Daniela
ya son varios los camiones que han
pasado de lado y lado de la frontera
tanto de empresas colombianas que están
haciendo envíos hacia Venezuela como de
Venezuela hacia Colombia principalmente
viene a cero desde el país vecino
Colombia está exportando principalmente
productos de aseo esto como el primer
paso de la normalización de relaciones
diplomáticas y también comerciales entre
Colombia y Venezuela vendrá ahora un
segunda una segunda etapa que consiste
en la apertura del paso vehicular
después de que ya se normalizara El paso
del transporte de carga eso será en las
próximas semanas según ha anunciado el
presidente Gustavo Petro quien dijo que
se habilitará el puente de tienditas un
puente que queda ubicado a unos 20
minutos de este el puente internacional
Simón Bolívar y que servirá para el
transporte de carga y también para el
transporte de vehículos intermunicipales
y de el transporte particular de
pasajeros los seguirán las las
restricciones existentes por ahora de
horario para el tránsito de personas por
este puente internacional que hoy en día
es de unos 30.000 personas Pero que en
su momento llegó a ser de unos 80.000 en
el momento más ácido de la migración de
venezolanos hacia Colombia el presidente
Gustavo Petro ha hecho eh un discurso
bastante corto de unos 12 minutos en el
que en el que señaló que no va a volver
a cerrar las fronteras entre ambos
países pero que adicionalmente hay mucho
para hacer mucha tarea por
adelantar con el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro y que lo hará en los próximos
meses ahora tomemos el pulso pero del
otro lado de la frontera del lado
venezolano ella se encuentra herminia
Fernández también enviada especial de
France 24 y nos da más detalles de cómo
ha sido la normalización allí Y cómo han
recibido esto los venezolanos escuchemos
llegó el esperado día en la frontera
Colombo venezolana se abrió el paso
formal que mejorará la calidad de vida
de los ciudadanos de ambas naciones el
acto simbólico se hizo con el paso de
unos camiones con mercancía de carga
tanto de Colombia como de Venezuela los
camiones venezolanos pasaron con láminas
de acero y vinieron desde el sur del
país los ciudadanos de los dos países
que pasan a diario no ocultaban su
alegría ya no tendrán que atravesar los
pasos ilegales para transportar la
mercancía de uso diario sin embargo aún
están a la expectativa de cuando se
reabrirá el paso de vehículos
particulares y también Cuál será el
documento requerido para pasar de manera
peatonal de un lado al otro los
venezolanos esperan que se arregle la
economía de la zona y también que se
generen empleos los colombianos que
continúe el flujo de intercambio de
productos falta por definir Claridad en
el tema de la seguridad y de las aduanas
para que realmente
vuelva un intercambio comercial seguro
también los grupos delictivos están en
la mira del gobierno venezolano para que
no se creen otros grupos de extorsión en
contra de los comerciantes Lo importante
es que los ciudadanos comunes esperan
resultados queda entonces sobre la mesa
de la pregunta obvia para analizar este
tema que representa para ambos países y
para la región latinoamericana el
restablecimiento de la región de las
relaciones y la apertura de la frontera
también el restablecimiento de los
vuelos y ese acercamiento entre Bogotá y
Caracas en términos políticos
comerciales y bueno a todo nivel pues lo
vamos a analizar ya de inmediato aquí en
el debate de francés 24 y para conversar
sobre este tema saludamos a Carmen
Beatriz Fernández ellos consultora
política de Data estrategia y también es
profesora de la Universidad de navarra
ella se conecta desde la ciudad de
Bilbao en España y aquí en el estudio de
France 24 nos acompaña Víctor Mijares
profesor de ciencia política y estudios
globales de la universidad los Andes que
está ubicada en la ciudad de Bogotá en
Colombia ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden dejar todos los
comentarios y preguntas que quieran a
través de las redes sociales ya lo saben
estamos en Twitter en instagram en
Facebook nos encuentran en arroba
france24_s@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal y también les recuerdo que
pueden escuchar todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa en nuestros podcast que
ya están disponibles en diferentes en
diferentes plataformas no se encuentran
en Apple podcast en Spotify deezer y
TuneIn vamos a comenzar entonces pues le
doy primero el saludo a Carmen Beatriz
en la ciudad de Bilbao en el norte de
España Carmen Beatriz Gracias por estar
con nosotros y Punto de partida Como me
gusta Llamar a la primera pregunta para
conocer opiniones de los invitados y El
Punto de partida en este caso pues tiene
que ser el significado a nivel político
de esta apertura y este reencuentro de
relaciones diplomáticas y comerciales
entre Bogotá y Caracas Cuál es el
balance que usted hace
Sí muchas gracias Santiago encantada
estar con ustedes mucho gusto Víctor
también
bueno en primer lugar creo que es una
buena noticia no O sea creo que que es
el consenso general de valorar este este
esta este reencuentro como una buena
noticia porque es un reencuentro entre
dos naciones
más que hermanas Pues de dos naciones
que prácticamente han sido durante mucho
tiempo
una misma nación un mismo pueblo una
frontera enorme Pero además muy vivan
una frontera muy porosa como ustedes
decían en su buen resumen inicial que
cuyo cuyo
cuyo cierre ha representado una tragedia
para una población enorme no Al final
este la trascendencia de esta decisiones
políticas siempre la parte más débil es
la que es la que lleva la peor parte no
Entonces al final quien venía sufriendo
todas las consecuencias del cierre de la
frontera venía siendo el pueblo Pues el
pueblo venezolano el pueblo colombiano
iba fundamentalmente quienes viven más
próximos a esa frontera que que aún
cerrada y ustedes lo decían en sus
estadísticas aún cerradas tiene unas
características de tal
bigorre y de tal porosidad que que
permitió un intercambio comercial de 300
millones de dólares anuales no O sea no
no no es poca cosa no es mucho menos de
lo que debía hacer pero pero nunca pudo
cerrarse O sea la realidad es que era
una frontera o ha venido siendo una
frontera que estaba
semiabierta y donde se facilitaba más
bien todos los caminos oscuros y todas
las vías alternativas todas las vías
todos los caminos verdes digamos
24 Víctor a Mijares bienvenido Gracias
por acompañarnos acá en el estudio y
Víctor la misma pregunta como Punto de
partida el significado que tiene esto a
nivel político para ambos países y
también para la estabilidad y la
tranquilidad de la región
latinoamericana bien obviamente debemos
tener un significado importantísimo para
ambos países para para la región Pero
antes de eso quisiera hacer una pequeña
precisión con respecto a algo que se
dijo al inicio que tiene que ver con ese
contexto Y es que las relaciones o el
empeoramiento esas relaciones empieza a
darse en 2018 Sí pero bajo el gobierno
de Juan Manuel Santos sobre todo en mayo
cuando se desconocen los resultados y
todo el proceso electoral que va a
llevar a la reelección de Nicolás maduro
y es en enero de 2019 cuando se proclama
Juan guaidó que efectivamente en ese
momento el presidente ya Iván Duque lo
reconoce entonces ahí aquí hay unos hay
unos tiempos que son importantes
recordarlos por una razón es decir hay
cierta continuidad entre la política
hacia Venezuela de El último Santos y lo
que va a hacer el resto del gobierno
Duque no que a veces tiende un poco como
como a olvidarse esto En cuanto a la
significación obviamente para toda
América Latina Yo creo que es una muy
buena noticia tomando en consideración
que hay desde luego unos problemas
sociales muy importantes hay una
población vulnerable que está
Generalmente asociado con esta migración
a partir de la crisis económica
venezolana y que esto abre la
oportunidad de la regularización de las
relaciones de la regularización no
solamente las relaciones diplomáticas
sino más más importantes que las
diplomáticas diría yo son las relaciones
consulares porque permite que
casi 2.5 millones de venezolanos que
vivimos en Colombia tengamos acceso a
representación consular Pero además
permite que los colombianos y hijos de
colombianos y otros colombianos que
todavía hacen vida en Venezuela un
número no determinado Aunque el
embajador Benedetti se ha atrevido un
poco a vuelvo a repetir las cifras
oficiales que el hace el gobierno
venezolano que ofrece un poco exagerado
de 5 millones pero no creo que sea esto
también necesitan esa asistencia
consular entonces hay una hay una una
relación que es absolutamente necesaria
absolutamente importante desde el punto
de vista comercial desde el punto de
vista de seguridad pero que también
tiene y genera algunas dudas con materia
por ejemplo de seguridad no hay mucha
Claridad ya es una reunión entre
ministros en la defensa Y por supuesto y
objetivos políticos de por medio el
objetivo del gobierno colombiano que es
el de incorporar a Venezuela o
reincorporar a Venezuela para el proceso
de lo que el presidente Gustavo Petro ha
llamado el proceso de la paz total para
que sea un garante frente al Ln y del
lado venezolano el interés de que
Colombia sea esa puerta de regreso a las
relaciones hemisféricas y sobre todo las
relaciones con América Latina punto
importante Ahí justamente esas
relaciones Víctor continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda la inversa ya le doy
la palabra a Carmen Beatriz en España
esas relaciones van completamente
distintas a lo que venía haciendo la
relación entre Colombia y Venezuela unas
relaciones marcadas por los altibajos
por el tire y afloje entre los gobiernos
de turno con maduristas o con chavistas
desde el lado que se que se quiera mirar
cómo van a hacer esas relaciones o cómo
pueden ser la construcción va a ser muy
difícil y es hilo por hilo pero como
puede llegar a ser esa relación que
claramente es diferente Yo creo que esa
relación digamos se ha querido empujar
esa relación por el lado económico y En
definitiva digamos Hay muchísimas
necesidades económicas y el mercado
natural de compra de productos
terminados productos agrícolas de
Venezuela siempre ha sido Colombia fue
una razón elemental Venezuela siempre ha
sido un país petrolero con una clarísima
tiene sobre todo en los últimos 20 años
una clarísima tendencia a la
monoproducción y la monoexportación
razón por la cual ha tenido una muy baja
producción agrícola una muy baja
producción industrial y Colombia suple
eso y el negocio de Colombia por
supuesto es vender la Venezuela
Venezuela que ha tenido históricamente
también por esa misma característica ser
un país petrolero una propensión muy
alta el consumo Es decir hay una hay una
tendencia al consumo que a veces un
poquito más allá de lo de lo necesario
por parte de él el consumidor venezolano
ahora bien hay ciertas condiciones que
hay que tomar en cuenta es decir
Venezuela en los últimos cinco siete
años perdió tres cuartas partes de su
del tamaño de su economía Hay una
dolarización que puede ser muy atractiva
para los comerciantes colombianos pero
una valorización que es informal
entonces hay muchas condiciones y además
Venezuela perdió 20% de su población en
los últimos años entonces hay una
Venezuela que es distinta hay unas
condiciones políticas que también son
distintas e inéditas es decir el el
chavismo va a dialogar por primera vez
con un gobierno de izquierda en Bogotá
no sabemos qué significa eso en
principio pareciera que esto implicaría
sintonía ideológica pero también podría
ser rivalidad ideológica por ver quién
es el líder de esa nueva izquierda
adicionalmente estamos viendo dos
versiones de la izquierda la dominicana
del lado venezolano una izquierda mucho
más lenista mucho más autoritaria mucho
más rígida y del lado de Colombia una
izquierda que trata de ser mucho más
progresista mucho más vinculada a los
temas vamos a llamarlo posmodernos la
temas sociales mucho más actuales
entonces hay muchas condiciones que como
bien dices tú hay que reconstruir esto
aparte y lo a hilo en unas condiciones
que son completamente inéditas para la
relación Colombo venezolana además que
términos de debate los países han
socialmente Venezuela se ha quedado
atrás en muchos debates supongamos solo
por poner uno por ejemplo el tema del
matrimonio igualitario o aborto aborto
ese tipo de cosas venezolanovado esos
debates a nivel social Colombia ya los
ha dado Entonces sí hay como una
diferencia por lo menos en términos
sociales de de como están insertados en
el mundo y en los grandes la palabra a
Carmen Beatriz ya vuelvo con usted
Víctor Canon Beatriz su perspectiva de
cómo va a ser esa relación si va a tener
va a ser una relación fundamentada en el
aspecto comercial que es lo que estamos
viendo mucho interés por parte de las
empresas colombianas por llegar a suplir
todo este mercado venezolano pero
también mucho interés por parte de los
pequeños empresarios venezolanos que han
desarrollado casi que una economía de
subsistencia con una cierta capacidad
limitada de exportación que puede llegar
a entrar a un mercado como el colombiano
por lo menos llegar a un mercado
fronterizo esa va a ser la base o es
simplemente una primera arista para
fundamentar una relación del largo
Calibre
creo que se está viendo como un primer
paso y Es lógico que sea así y es un
primer paso muy importante no O sea al
final tú con quién comercias te
entiendes no al final con que si tú
tienes un intercambio comercial si tú le
vendes a un vecino pues no tienes
interés en enemistarte con ese vecino y
y creo que que eso ese es un comienzo
muy importante pero yo creo que que no
se debe que que que que se debe ir más
allá y se debe ir
al complejo de esa relación entre Petro
y Maduro que existe una relación y que
existe una afinidad y que existe una
afinidad desde hace muchos años que fue
deliberadamente ocultada durante la
campaña electoral creo que que que que
de de de como un acuerdo posiblemente
entre las partes que otra vez se hace
explícita hoy cuando En este acto tan
vistoso que hemos visto hoy en la en la
frontera de la apertura de la frontera
pues falta notoriamente Nicolás maduro y
posiblemente
pueda de alguna manera verse como como
un desplante que que le hace
Petro a maduro primero diciendo que no
iba a la frontera después yendo a última
hora y haciendo este acto muy colorido
pero que evidentemente parece Claro que
maduro no era bienvenido en esa foto y
maduro no era bienvenido en esa foto
porque pues probablemente porque maduro
representa un daño reputacional para
Petro y Petro lo percibe así o lo
percibía así en campaña y lo sigue
persiguiendo así en el gobierno no
entonces
dudo que haya un político más rechazado
que maduro en Colombia
usted entonces que esta falta de
presencia de un alto representante del
gobierno de maduro porque solamente fue
el ministro de transporte
Ramón Velázquez no es porque Venezuela
le está restando importancia al hecho de
la apertura sino porque estratégicamente
y políticamente hablando no conviene que
maduro hubiera estado en la frontera por
lo menos para este gobierno de Petro que
está comenzando no
le convenían bueno estaba estaba
presente el canciller Plasencia y estaba
presente también el gobernador Bernal no
Además del ministro de transporte pero
evidentemente faltaba maduro bueno
fue fue una ausencia notoria no esto que
es mensaje se le está enviando entonces
a la a la a la comunidad está Venezuela
intentando abrirse pero restándole ahí
un poco de peso o estratégicamente aquí
le están apostando esa que Petro tome
cierto peso a nivel internacional y
ciertos liderazgo por lo menos en esta
integración de Venezuela o en ese
reaparición de Venezuela en el escenario
mundial Bueno hasta los momentos tenemos
dos hipótesis dice que esto tuvo que ver
un poco con esa idea de tratar sacar a
Nicolás Maduro en la foto lo que tú
planteas tiene que ver más con la idea
de está asociado Pero tiene que ver más
como con la idea de que Petro asuma más
liderazgo y que eso no le afecte su
margen de maniobra política y también
podríamos tener una una hipótesis un
poco más accidentada y tiene que ver
también con la idea de los mensajes un
poco
erráticos no del presidente Petro que no
se sabía si iba o si no iba y al parecer
ahí Nicolás Maduro también vio que no
iba a aparecer el solo digamos
recibiendo Esa esa apertura Entonces
digamos en este momento estamos en el en
el terreno las especulaciones y de
elaboración de hipótesis yo sí creo que
más allá de las hipótesis si hay
obviamente como dice Carmen Beatriz un
costo reputacional de tomarse la
fotografía con con Nicolás Maduro porque
aunque todo el mundo sepa que maduro ha
sido invitado a ser garante otra cosa es
aparecer en la foto en ese en ese acto
en particular
estrechándose la mano pero también
protocolariamente hay un problema no es
decir que estrecho de manos es con un
ministro que la extracción de Manos no
es como homólogo sino con un gobernador
entonces ahí también hay un problema
serio que hay que tomar en cuenta
eventualmente Va a tener que haber una
relación directa al menos de
comunicación y se va a terminar
asociando el nombre de Petro con el de
maduro creo que del lado Nicolás Maduro
Sí hay interés en que Colombia insisto
yo en esta idea sea la puerta grande de
reingreso a la política hemisférica que
Colombia sea esa puerta grande y del
lado de Petro hay una necesidad porque
sabe que el lln consigue tiene confianza
en el gobierno venezolano a pesar de que
Venezuela se ha convertido un poco en la
tumba de muchos de muchos disidentes de
La FARC pero el Ln digamos ha tenido una
muy buena acogida allí y es
absolutamente necesario tener una buena
relación entonces con Caracas para
lograr esa negociación y sobre todo ese
proyecto de paz total Víctor hay muchos
retos entonces en esta abertura en esta
apertura de la de la frontera perdón y
uno de los puntos principales es
justamente la lucha contra el
contrabando el tráfico de personas las
trochas clandestinas que es por donde la
gente cruza la frontera de un lado a
otro todas estas mafias que han tomado
lugar allí esto es un reto muy grande y
sobre todo porque hay presencia
guerrillera hay presencia de grupos
paramilitares Mejor dicho es el caldo de
cultivo perfecto para todos los los
problemas sociales y económicos y
políticos que tienen ambos países
panorama de cómo se puede empezar a
atacar este tipo de problemáticas allí
Pues yo creo que ahí adicionalmente
estos problemas unas condiciones que
unas han cambiado y otras no es decir en
torno a Venezuela Todo cambió excepto
Venezuela es decir cambió el que vieron
los gobiernos en los Estados Unidos
cambiar desde el digo desde desde que
comienzan los problemas de ese cierre de
fronteras de ese de
ese eh Esa desmejó en la relación
bilateral en 2015 Pues digamos ya hemos
tenido a Obama hemos tenido Trump y
ahora tenemos a biden en el caso en el
caso de de de de de Colombia El
presidente Santos el presidente Duque y
ahora el presidente Petro mientras que
en Venezuela Todo se mantiene más o
menos igual Es decir lo que ha
demostrado Nicolás Maduro Es que la ha
resistido todo ha cambiado a su
alrededor y vuelve a ser favorable para
su política pero cuando hablamos de esa
estabilidad en el sistema venezolano
también hablamos por ejemplo de la
corrupción que se ha denunciado que ha
penetrado a sus fuerzas militares y a la
guardia nacional y que parte de esas
mafias También tienen mucho que ver con
la corrupción de las fuerzas de
seguridad del Estado venezolano eso no
va a cambiar de la noche a la mañana hay
muchos negocios que tienen que ver por
supuesto con el tráfico de personas pero
también con el tráfico estupefacientes
el tráfico de alimentos y el tráfico de
documentos que es otro elemento y muy
importante en el caso venezolano
entonces creo que hay algunos elementos
que se pueden tratar desde la
perspectiva bila Pero hay otros
problemas que no se pueden tratar sino
que son restrictivos y unilaterales
tienen que ver directamente con
Venezuela y ahí poco puede hacer
Colombia Más allá de tratar de generar
algún tipo de presión amistosa
diplomática consular para que esos
problemas se vayan resolviendo pues por
lo menos del lado colombiano Carmen
Beatriz se muestran muy optimistas el
embajador Benedetti dijo textualmente le
vamos a arrancar la frontera a las
mafias Y eso va a traer problemas de
seguridad pero es algo a lo que están
dispuestos a jugarse el todo por el todo
esto que significa para ese
restablecimiento de las relaciones puede
haber allí incremento de problemas de
seguridad de
ataques sí inseguridad en todo el
sentido de la palabra
Sí bueno ojalá ojalá y y y y
ojalá que se sea realidad esa aplicación
del embajador Benedetti pero no se puede
perder de vista que las mafias están
vinculadas a las extrañas del propio
gobierno venezolano o sea las mafias de
la frontera están vinculadas a las
fuerzas armadas Pues si son resquicios y
son espacios que tienen la propia
fuerzas armadas para para el pues ese
esa tanto para el contrabando de
mercancías como para el contrabando de
personas y eso son
obstáculos digamos al libre tránsito
porque
la frontera cerrada implicó el
desarrollo de negocios paralelos Esa esa
es una realidad o sea toda todo esto que
decimos de mafias no son unas mafias
asociadas a un tercer sector sino
las propias entrañas del monstruo
digamos o sea y ahí está lo lo delicado
y ahí yo creo que está la serie de
Zig Zag y y y y altibajos que ha tenido
esta serie de anuncios no O sea no
estamos viendo una apertura inmediato y
total de la frontera sino que se estima
una apertura progresiva claro uno puede
entender que Colombia con todas sus
dificultades que pueda tener a nivel
político y diplomático es un país que
Respeta los estatutos Internacionales
los organismos Los acuerdos caso
contrario se puede decir de Venezuela
que es un país que responde
algunas veces de forma errática y
algunas veces pues no es muy garante de
muchos acuerdos y aquí lo que necesita
tal vez tanto la región como Colombia
son garantías Y tal vez por eso puede
uno entender esa necesidad que está
haciendo el gobierno de Bogotá por
intentar que Venezuela vuelva a un marco
por ejemplo como el de la comunidad
andina o el de la corte intera pierna de
derechos esto puede ser fácil de
alcanzar por parte de Caracas con ayuda
de Colombia con ayuda de Bogotá y pueden
ser garantías para Colombia para esto
que se está jugando aquí el todo por el
todo en la frontera yo estoy
Completamente de acuerdo con eso y me
parece que la estrategia que quiere
seguir el gobierno de Gustavo Petro
frente a Venezuela es de algún modo
reinsertarla darle la posibilidad de que
se inserta también en foros políticos
que vuelva a tener el control por
ejemplo no solamente de monómeros
asuntos más locales que tienen que ver
con la relación Colombo venezolana sino
que por ejemplo que Venezuela vuelva a
tener representante el gobierno de
maduro vuelve a tener representante en
la oea por ejemplo y no el representante
del gobierno de Juan guaidó que es el
que sigue allí sino que se inserte o se
reinserte plenamente naturalmente a
cambio de que acepte ciertas condiciones
que el gobierno colombiano necesita como
garantías mínimas para poder negociar
entonces parece una estrategia de muy
largo plazo para tratar de mantener o
digamos
de volver a Venezuela a un marco que
permite esas garantías ahora bien Muchas
de esas garantías podrían ir en contra
la estabilidad y la continuidad del
propio gobierno venezolano el gobierno
venezolano digamos no puede por ejemplo
ofrecer garantías electorales plenas
porque eso puede poner en riesgo su
propia continuidad entonces allí vamos a
ver un un unas tensiones un tira y
afloje verdad Entre el gobierno
venezolano y el gobierno colombiano en
donde además tenemos saboteadores no es
decir el señor Dios dado cabello por
ejemplo que tiene que aunque Nicolás
Maduro diga algo en el día Dios ha dado
cabello que es el número 2 de régimen
venezolano tiene un programa en la noche
que lanza y tiene una línea paralela la
línea más radical del partido y que
muchas veces puede ser digamos de algún
modo ese ese juego del policía bueno el
policía malo Dios dado cabello está
completamente dispuesto a hacer ese
juego y muchas veces puede dinamitar
ciertas condiciones y acuerdos que se
puedan alcanzar es por eso es que este
acuerdo muy importante pero también es
muy frágil es muy frágil es importante
Carmen Beatriz y justamente llevar a
Venezuela a estos escenarios
internacionales y también este
reconocimiento que le está dando Bogotá
a Nicolás Maduro dejando de lado ese
reconocimiento que le había dado a Juan
guaidó también le da un poco de oxígeno
más al chavismo al madurismo a Nicolás
Maduro en el poder al gobierno que está
allí en Caracas y también
puede ser
un Punto de partida para un efecto bola
de nieve porque recordemos que Colombia
y Estados Unidos fueron dos de los
países que intentaron apalancar a Juan
guaidó a nivel internacional y ahora
Colombia está yéndose por el otro lado
está volviendo a conversar directamente
con maduro esto Qué mensaje le está
mandando al mundo
sí sin duda el occidente ha dado
muestras de de incoherencia en relación
al tema venezolano y y contra Venezuela
se aplicó una estrategia de Máximo
aislamiento y máxima presión que no
funcionó
es lo no hay duda de que no funcionó Por
qué no funcionó bueno por muchas razones
entre otras algunas un par de carambolas
que que no estaban en el escenario que
nadie pudo prever las pero el mundo
cambió radicalmente en mi Venezuela ni
Colombia ni el mundo es hoy el mismo
mundo que eran 2019 no O sea la pandemia
cambió el mundo y y luego de la pandemia
la Guerra de Ucrania está cambiando
Europa está cambiando la configuración
geopolítica del mundo Entonces ambas
cosas de alguna manera beneficiaron a
Nicolás Maduro no hicieron que occidente
guiar a sus prioridades y y también que
occidente Viera en Venezuela un enemigo
que no era tan peligroso y con el que se
podía incluso negociar y llegar a
algunos acuerdos eso esa es la entonces
maduro este este round lo ganó y siente
que lo ganó no vamos entrando ya en
volver a la empresa negociación de
México entre otras cosas vamos llegando
ya la parte final del programa y
continuó con Carmen para ya darle la
palabra Víctor un poquito más adelante
paso a preguntarle ahora también por las
garantías para los empresarios
recordemos por ejemplo el caso de las
aerolíneas colombianas la cantidad de
dinero que tienen todavía enterrado en
Venezuela después de haber operado allí
durante años que no pudieron repatriar
sus sus sus sus ganancias y esto también
originó que no solamente las aerolíneas
colombianas sino muchas empresas
colombianas o u otros países del Mundo
tuvieron que abandonar la operación
aérea en Venezuela hay garantías
jurídicas hay garantías económi para las
empresas que van a llegar allí en este
caso pues van a llegar en gran medida
empresas colombianas
cualquier transacción
una institucionalidad y la existencia de
unas normas claras esas normas claras no
existen en Venezuela hoy por hoy Esa esa
es la realidad pues no entonces
evidentemente por eso entre otras cosas
la apertura va a ser progresiva y el
restablecimiento de las relaciones
comerciales va a ser progresiva en la
medida que vaya existiendo una confianza
y existiendo un una evolución sí Víctor
aquí en el estudio de France 24 vemos
Que Colombia está jugando intereses
económicos intereses políticos el
capital político de un presidente que
está comenzando la seguridad en la
frontera un proceso de paz con grupos
armados Colombia está apostando mucho
leyendo algunos de los análisis sobre
este tema decían que Colombia está
caminando sobre piso de cristal así es y
la propia Apuesta por la paz total la
propiedad de paz total es una idea muy
atractiva muy atrayente muy muy muy
impactante pero también muy frágil
porque porque la paz total es una
apuesta tan alta que cualquier mínimo
error en esa totalidad de los objetivos
puede ser visto como un costo enorme
para Gustavo Petro él parece estar
confiando en el capital político parece
estar confiando en la idea de que es un
gobierno de cambio es un gobierno nuevo
Un gobierno que va puede tener cierto
margen de maniobra Aunque el mismo ha
dicho que ellos no tienen margen de
maniobra y quizás una de sus apuestas
más importantes en esta Paz total en
este en esta nueva situación es
precisamente confiar en el gobierno
venezolano hay razones de sobra para
creer que el gobierno venezolano no es
precisamente Un gobierno muy de fiar que
no ofrecer ofrece garantías y que eso
puede dañar digamos perjudicar
grandemente a la estrategia de Gustavo
Petro en esa Paz total a la estrategia
incluso económica va a haber también un
interés por parte de Venezuela de
instrumentalizar a Colombia como un
lobista Si se quiere para levantar las
sanciones parte de lo que decía un rato
acerca de esas deudas que tiene empresas
colombianas en Venezuela Venezuela ya
está dando a entender que si lo ayuda a
que se levante las sanciones ellos van a
tener la posibilidad de pagar parte de
eso es cierto parte de ellos no es tan
cierto pero va a tratar de insertarse en
esa relación con Colombia va a tratar de
mantener una relación muy estrecha con
Colombia para que Colombia sea de algún
modo ese ese puente hacia el mundo de
las garantías el mundo sobre todo de las
de la inserción insisto la reinserción
en el mundo civil y sobre todo las
relaciones diplomáticas hemisféricas
claro y también puede ser un puente con
Washington una relación que también
necesita en este momento Estados Unidos
mejorar con Venezuela por todo el tema
energético y el petróleo que lo está
necesitando a raíz de lo que está
sucediendo en Ucrania me quedan para
minutos Víctor continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda la inversa para el cierre
Venezuela como garante de esa
negociación que puede haber con el Ln
con los grupos delincuenciales Como por
ejemplo el clan del Golfo que puede dar
Venezuela en esta negociación Más allá
de estar jugando a hacer la retaguardia
delln A qué juega Venezuela allí qué
puedo ofrecer pues lo que puedo ofrecer
es la sede una sede importante para
dialogar una sede en donde el Ln y otros
grupos se puedan seguir más sentir más
seguros en donde no haya digamos
posibilidad por ejemplo en tanto hay una
relación que aunque ha venido de algún
modo reconstruyéndose pero que no
termina de cuajar hay una relación rota
con los Estados Unidos pues se pueden
sentir mucho más seguros en territorio
venezolano además
han gozado Hasta cierto punto de ciertos
privilegios en ese territorio han
dominado parte del territorio incluso
dan ha incursionado en negocios digamos
bastante nuevos para el ADN como la
minería por ejemplo Se pueden sentir
seguros en ese territorio al menos
parcialmente seguros en su territorio
más allá de eso es muy poco lo que puedo
ofrecer es decir más allá de eso las
garantías pueden ser por ejemplo la del
secreto y eso puede ser muy importante
tanto para el lln como para el gobierno
colombiano porque recordemos que en
Venezuela bajo la doctrina de la
hegemonía comunicacional Pues los medios
de comunicación no son tan libres ni
tienen tacto a tanto acceso a la Fuente
pública razón por la cual así como se
negoció con La FARC en la Habana en
donde estaba comunicaciónmente aislados
podrían hacer lo mismo en Caracas o en
cualquier otro lugar de la geografía
venezolanos elementos que puede ofrecer
hermetismo allí en Venezuela me queda un
minuto rápidamente las conclusiones
Carmen Beatriz que sigue entonces en
este reinicio de las relaciones Bogotá
Caracas que vamos a ver en los próximos
días meses en esta relación rápidamente
por favor
Sí bueno a lo económico se supone que
debe seguir lo político y y esta y esta
petición de santos de que maduro actúa
como garante del Ln por un lado reconoce
digamos la la la afinidad entre el lln y
maduro Pero por otro lado abre la puerta
a acuerdos políticos donde eventualmente
la reciprocidad podría indicar que
maduro pidiera que
Santos o Colombia fuera también garante
o acompañante del proceso de
negociaciones en México hay un Nou house
de negociaciones triangulado con la
Habana que lo mencionaba Víctor y creo
que Que bueno que veían en cosas
seguirán vendiendo cosas en esta
progresividad
me dicen que ya debo cortar el programa
porque va a dar paso al informativo
Víctor le agradezco mucho por haber
estado con nosotros y a Carmen Beatriz
en la ciudad de Bilbao también ustedes
Muchas gracias la producción estuvo a
cargo de Laura garzón y la producción de
vamos a cargo de Tania Herrera siga con
nosotros
[Música]